necesitamos hacer dos conversiones tres
kilogramos a miligramos y cuatro
toneladas a onzas este es claramente en
el sistema métrico mientras que esta es
en el sistema de unidades usuales en
eeuu
te invito a que pongas pausa e intentes
hacer las conversiones tú solo para
hacer esta conversión tenemos que
recordar que lo que significan estos
prefijos para hacer esto voy a
reescribir lo tenemos 3 kilogramos 3
kilogramos que queremos convertir a 1000
gramos a 1000 gramos y lo que ya sabemos
es que el prefijo kilo significa 1000
mientras que el prefijo mili significa 1
sobre 1000 o una milésima de gramo
convirtamos primero de kilogramos a
gramos y luego haremos la conversión de
gramos a miligramos tenemos entonces qué
3 kilogramos es igual a 3 x
milk
3 x 1000 gramos 3 x 1000 gramos esto es
igual a 3 mil gramos es igual a
gramos 3 kilogramos literalmente 3000
gramos y eso es lo que obtenemos 3000
gramos y ahora como convertimos de
gramos a miligramos bien aquí ya
mencionamos que un miligramo es una
milésima de gramo voy a ponerlo por aquí
un miligramo es igual a una milésima de
gramo otra manera de expresar esto es
que un gramo equivale a mil miligramos
así es que si un gramo equivale a mil
miligramos si tenemos tres mil de esos
gramos esto equivale a tres mil por mil
miligramos vamos a hacerlo por acá esto
es equivalente a los tres mil gramos que
tenemos por mil miligramos que hay en
cada gramo así es que al hacer este
producto obtenemos el número de
miligramos y esto cuánto nos da aquí
tenemos tres mil y sabemos que cada mil
miles es un millón así es que tres mil
por mil van a ser tres millones
así es que esto nos da
tres millones tres millones de
miligramos otra manera de hacer esta
multiplicación es aquí tengo 30 seguido
de 3 ceros son 6 ceros y aquí tengo 3 x
1 es 3 seguido de seis ceros 3 millónes
de miligramos y ahora hagamos esta
conversión de 4 toneladas cortas del
sistema usual de eeuu y onzas y para
esto primero vamos a convertir toneladas
a libras sabemos que cada tonelada cada
tonelada corta cada tonelada equivale a
2.000 libras
2000 libras así es que si tenemos 4
toneladas esto va a ser equivalente si
cada tonelada tiene 2000 libras esto va
a ser 4 por 2 mil libras y esto es igual
a 8 mil 8 mil libras 8 mil libras ahora
para convertir libras a onzas sabemos
que cada libra tiene sabemos que deja de
ponerlo aquí con otro color sabemos que
cada libra cada libre equivale a 16
onzas
así es que 8 mil libras que son las 4
toneladas 8 mil libras
equivalen a 8 mil por 16 onzas 8 mil por
16 onzas que hay en cada libra y esto
cuánto nos da bueno veamos 8 por 6 48
llevamos 48 por 18 y 4 12 son 128 y 3
ceros que tenemos aquí 128 mil 128 mil
onzas
así es que 4 toneladas 4 toneladas
cortas son muchísimas onzas